We're going to focus here on
optimizing for Sharpe ratio.
So solving that problem is not trivial,
but it's not too hard either.
What we need to do is frame
the portfolio optimization problem as
a minimization problem, and
then we can solve it using
the tools you have already.
As you recall, in order to use
a optimizer that minimizes,
we have to do three things.
First, we have to provide a function
to minimize f(x) that takes in x, two,
an initial guess for that x, and three,
call the optimizer and let it run.
Now, in this case, x are the allocations
that we're looking for.
And we want the optimizer to try
different allocations in order
to discover the best set of allocations
that optimizes this function.
Well, what is that function exactly?
We said just a moment ago that we
want to optimize for Sharpe ratio.
So, is this just a Sharpe ratio?
Well not exactly, because what
the minimizer will do, in this case,
is try to find
the smallest Sharpe ratio.
So it'll find allocations
that minimize that.
And we want, of course,
the largest Sharpe ratio,
because larger Sharpe ratios are better.
That's easy to fix.
All we do is multiply
this by negative 1.
So, all that we want our optimizer to do
is optimize for a negative Sharpe ratio.
And that'll find the best allocation or
the best value for
x to solve this problem.
And remember,
x can have multiple dimensions,
so each dimension of x here is
an allocation to each of the stocks.
So, if we're trying to solve for
a portfolio of four stocks,
x will have four dimensions, and
the value for each of those dimensions
is the percentage of funds to
allocate to each of those stocks.